du piton à la longue rue principale de
l'école au stade municipal à saint
joseph tout porte son nom un jour férié
les portes sont closes la ville est
morte mais la mémoire elle reste bien
vivante
ici raphaël babet un mystère pour
personne mais pourquoi donc c'était
monsieur amer l'ancien maire de saint
philippe à saint-philippe qu'un symbole
qu'il était aussi député socialiste fait
très populaire à grands pas la taille
qu'en face au talent c'est lui qui a
envoyé pas mal de trucs que cela ça
talent qui a créé la police avant de
mourir ils ont dit bon il faut montrer
en eau de boudin sur le piton ses yeux
face à l'océan en face à madagascar
raphaël babet dernier né d'une famille
de cinq enfants voient le jour en 1894 à
saint pierre cinq ans plus tard il est
orphelin de père et de mère dès 16 ans
il commence donc une vie d'aventurier en
s'embarquant comme boy pour marseille
puis il part en campagne de pêche dans
les îles saint paul et amsterdam avant
de s'installer à madagascar lors de la
guerre de 14 18 il s'engage dans le
bataillon d'infanterie coloniale de
lorient puis dans l'aviation de chasse
il reste ensuite en métropole jusqu'à la
fin de la deuxième guerre mondiale
de là il se lance dans la politique est
créée en 1933 la démocratie l'organe de
presse des républicains indépendants du
prolétariat de la réunion de retour au
pays il est élu maire de saint joseph où
il oeuvre pour le développement de la
commune il y construit un hôpital
la plus grande école d'agriculture de la
région la mairie et le marché couvert
mais ce qui le préoccupe le plus c'est
le chômage c'est pourquoi il encourage
les migrations réunionnaise dans le
périmètre de la sakay à madagascar une
ville sera même créé à sa mémoire sur
place à belleville élu député en 1946 il
défendra bec et ongles les dossiers de
son île jusqu à sa mort en 1957
il est enterré debout face à la mer et
une stèle à sa mémoire a été érigé à
babeth ville